hey everybody what's going on my name is
Aaron and welcome to the first Team Coco
hangout on Google+ all right awesome
very exciting right applause applause we
like that well done we have a bunch of
great fans who submitted video questions
to us on Google+ and we selected our
favorites and they are joining us
tonight from left to right we've got
Barry Worthington hey Barry how's it
going good how you doing Barry is where
I you live right outside of DC your
independent filmmaker very exciting I
love the hair looking good looking
really good and next to him we have
Frederick Johnson Patrick how's it goin
how are you I love your bike that's an
amazing looking microphone you are up in
the San Francisco Bay Area you're a
professional photographer I'm reading
all these off of blurbs that you guys
sent me so yes exactly
thanks for joining us Frederick next to
Frederick we have Jason major how's it
going Jason it's going great thanks I
love it are you listening to music
you're listening to the hanging out I'm
listening to you fantastic fantastic
Jason is a graphic designer and a space
blogger awesome that's fantastic I love
it
and next to Jason we have Sarah Kane how
are you Sarah hi here and I'm doing
great and Sarah you are studying for
your PhD in linguistics at Rice
University is that correct yes I'm
trying to check it along all right well
we're gonna be relying on you to speak
properly
and keep us all in our improper grammar
this evening and our final hour
participant is surely low how are you
Shirley I'm Dan great hyerin and you're
also from DC right you live in DC you've
got an awesome fish poster in the back
there thank you so much fantastic
what's that takes again yeah we took the
photo a couple months ago wow she makes
her own posters ladies and gentlemen
fantastic unbelievable all right well
thank you guys for joining us and now
without further ado please welcome mr.
Conan O'Brien
how are ya
here is hey Conan how's everyone doing
very nice to see you
Frederik Jason I believe Sara see what
surely how are you come and get her you
I'm really good and and I should point
out that that's Erin a Blair who is our
moderator he works with me he's been
with me for a long time and he also
plays the giant who carries bran around
on Game of Thrones
and that's correct yeah so look for him
he's uncredited in that role my office
I'm hearing Warner Brothers on the lot
they shoot the voice literally 20 feet
that way if you can imagine that way
that you'd see the voice the show The
Voice you shoot that right over there
and I'm right here really in a very
unacceptable and they I think take it
out using some kind of machine when you
see it on the air but here it really
sounds like an ancient tomb opening
years every time CeeLo turns around -
and the country guy who nobody ever goes
with him the country guy turns around
every time and says I'd be happy to and
they're like that's good
this will stick with CeeLo Pristina
but I don't really know why is there but
enough about them we'll get back to the
voice a little bit later on I thought we
should talk about you and get to your
questions I'm told we only have this 14
hours we have how much time do we have
right you guys 1 to 14 hours got nowhere
to go
my camping a marriage a little rocky why
is it funny
why is it funny that my marriage is on
the rocks
I have nowhere to go I'm sorry I lost my
temper I'm probably setting the wrong
tone everything's fine at home
got a little fun I find this very
dehumanizing it's good to know that some
of you have survived the zombie
apocalypse and that we can all
communicate this way Los Angeles I
understand one of yous in Norway and a
Shack
something else is in a meat locker in
Australia
remember headshots take the zombies out
let's begin with your questions Aaron
you're really doing a terrible job Bob I
can't get a word in edgewise all right
our first question is Barry you ready
Barry hit Conan with your question very
America correctly you are a photographer
is that right no I'm a filmmaker
yeah but isn't it really the same thing
nonliving images its photographer is
taking a still filmmakers taking a lot
of stills and putting them together to
make motion I yes very good Barry you're
learning how television works okay
always agree with Conan what is it Barry
well my question to you is who have you
always wanted to interview now this
could be somebody who's living or dead
fictional or non-fictional who you
always wanted okay
that's if they're okay if they're dead
are they am i interviewing them as there
would be if they were alive back in
their time or are they a rotting mutated
monster do you don't I mean just saying
people say and they can be dead and then
you say okay Abraham Lincoln and then
you never told me it's one of those
deals with the devil where then I go our
next guest is Abraham Lincoln and this
monster comes out you know he's like for
school and then he chokes the life out
of me and drinks my eye socket I I got I
mean I didn't think of that when I came
up with the question boy
III apologize so typical of all
photographers laughs all right I'm gonna
go with let's say there you're talking
them back in their time in their error
okay but then they don't know who I am
you come like a President Lincoln Conan
O'Brien here and they're like yeah and I
say I'm from TV and they're like what's
TV he says by the way you're Irish why
aren't you fighting for the north right
now and then I say but but but and he
gives me a musket and I'm dead of like a
disease really fast but I'm gonna go
with Lincoln I love Abraham Lincoln I
know it's kind of an obvious one but if
they're dead I would say Abraham Lincoln
alive I'd love to talk to
Woody Allen never met the man he's one
of my comedy heroes and absolutely loved
to talk to Woody Allen not just about
his movies but about his prose his short
stories I think he's one of the great
writing stylists of the late 20th
century I really he's had a huge
influence on me and so I'd love to talk
to him but again I don't know if that's
ever gonna happen
cool awesome all right Frederick let's
hear your question for Conan all right I
have a two-part question Conan two parts
what parts I got it's the same question
though Frederick I have a nine part
response to each of your questions
that's over 65 wait that's not right
hold on I need to work this out okay
well listen you go ahead and ask me your
questions that's what we're here to do
let's go let's do okay so who was the
best guest that you've ever ever
interviewed and who was the worst okay
kind of hard to do the worst because
they're on in a week again
then you know I I don't know is
interesting here's what I'm gonna do
okay I'm not going to say the best cuz
that's very hard to do I will tell you
some of the people that I absolutely
love Will Ferrell makes me laugh so hard
that I bleed into my pants which
actually doctors say has nothing to do
with me laughing that's just your
rupture down there it's how much now
well I love Will Ferrell I also love nor
McDonald because he comes on and his
stories are all invented none of them
are real they're all old farmers
daughters jokes and he pretends they
just he'll come on I'll say what's up
normally by other days walking down the
walking on the road and a pirate comes
up pigs with them a hat one's got a pipe
and then it's just a complete waste of
everybody's time that's absolutely
delightful and hilarious and so I love
him and I love Will and Tom Hanks is
always that rare combination of someone
who's you know incredibly famous Golden
Age television star who also his thing
never gets old his schtick never gets
old he's just always hilariously funny
so those are three people I absolutely
love and I like sometimes when really
beautiful women are on I become every I
revert to the awkward 14 year old Conan
who just wants to make them laugh and
it's very I just go to this other place
and I sometimes actually believe that
I'm on a date and that it's going well
they came out and they made eye contact
with me and so you know who they're
they're out there and it's like Oh
Angelina Jolie is looking at me she's
talking to me she seems interested in
what I'm saying she's answering my
questions just touch my arm and then my
reptile brain the most primitive part of
my brain says
she likes you ask her out and then and
then I say we'll take a break we'll be
right back
and they stand up and they walk away and
back phone off and I never they go into
a bubble you know a metallic bubble and
they're fired off to the next show
so those are the kind of guests I like
the guests I dislike without getting
really specific I can't stand it when
people take themselves too seriously I
talk about their process and their craft
I won't have it I won't have it all I
really do in the 19th and 18th century
actors and comedians we were all thought
of as like you know third-class citizens
we were like you show people you have to
use the rear entrance okay you can't eat
in this restaurant your show folk and I
really believe that for some sick reason
our society now deifies celebrities and
I think it's crazy i I think we should
it should be today we've got it upside
down I think people like me I should not
be allowed to into a restaurant I'm I'm
a sad ridiculous zone who's working out
my issues with my parents in front of
America and it's pathetic and I should
be kept to the side
I should be ignored I believe that
that's true in some restaurants you're
not allowed inside in LA okay now listen
to me I love her worked on Game of
Thrones great jump around and he can't
walk Godspeed
we love you for it but you've got to not
break in the Masters talking
this is our working dynamic by the way
Erin Blair is in a room outside my room
were he here with me I would hit him
really hard in the arm and if enough of
you agree that you want to see that I
will leave the chair walk to him and
punch him really hard arm but that's
your call I need all of you to agree
that you want to see that unanimously
that's one hand up nope certainly come
on
surely wait is everyone literally go
again Oh Frederick in Jason Sara in
watch this at least I thought sure you
help me no please nope okay one play
player right there yeah I hope you're
happy I hope you think that was barbaric
and cruel I want you to know there is a
cerebral intellectual side to Conan
O'Brien
next question anybody alright let's go
to Jason Jason you have a question now
you've sold me out and I'm horribly
bruised but you know I mean if this
actually were a game of Thrones you
would be eviscerated right now so I
guess you know you have you have to take
take the good with the bad
thank you I'm curious I just got here
and I'm new to this technology why are
you the only one wearing earbuds I am I
am wearing surely is wearing your buzzes
wait oh oh you're selling out a way you
could I will sell it out Shirley Shirley
Shirley has this beautiful hair during
her ear buds you sold her out for your
own gain she can't come through the door
back here lunch me in the office I'm
gonna come you know what Google has the
technology it's gonna be to your house
Jason I'm gonna punch your punch you out
all right I'm sorry there was a question
there silly what you got what's your
question Jason all right well Conan I
know you're a big fan of Science and
Technology well who said well I'm
getting the impression you're a big fan
of science and that's what you want to
talk about and suddenly I'm a big fan of
science now your first guest was I'm
Hanks in your new studio over there so I
and Tom
your eyes are getting very wide Jason
you're having kind of crazy you're like
I saw Hank I did well well Hanks played
Jim Lovell in Apollo 13 and correct he
also produced that fabulous series from
the earths to the moon yes so so that
leads me to believe that you respect
what he does and respect his work and I
know you wouldn't sell out I know you
wouldn't I wouldn't it's all impossible
he's a huge star he was willing to come
on the show and I said yes and I don't
know diddly about the moon but let's
pretend I do not travel through time
Jason I love more things lunar what's
your question well my question to you
Conan is what are your hopes about the
future of space exploration you know
what I'm glad you asked
clad you asked because when you're
talking to a late-night comedian best
thing to do was probably get his
thoughts on the colonization of other
planets I'm looking forward to it the
way I look at it those are other markets
that are going to be very reliant on
television let's imagine you're on Pluto
and you're there you're gonna have to
watch a lot of television you don't I
mean and after a while yes I know
there's video games and things like that
but to me that's really a captive
audience and so my entire interest in
space exploration is mostly Oh TBS could
probably sell television to those
planets to explorers there do I care if
they find life or find a renewable
energy source not really but if they can
create a couple of hundred thousand more
paying viewers in the Turner system I'm
in so I'm very excited about space
exploration for my own selfish reasons
awesome the business eats them he's a
businessman he's not just a comedian
he's a shrewd businessman was that
necessary well I just I'm trying
it's a segue I'm trying
that way here where where this is you
don't need a segue all right I need a
segue you just say your time has ended
before let's go we will now be Mewtwo
your next generation that's not I mean
come on I wasn't kidding no would you
like me to I feel like I haven't
satisfied you with my answer no I
haven't no I just haven't I don't know
what to do other than to make you happy
other than maybe put on a fake mustache
that's the only thing I can think to do
at this moment because I don't have a
good answer to your question and it's an
old it's an old adage and showbiz when
you can't answer a question you put on
the old fake stache now I would like to
this is a little pervy if I if I saw
this guy on the Internet
I would shut it down I'd ripped the
computer out of the wall I apologize
this is not a good look for me I'm gonna
take this off it goes up here I don't
know I'm just trying to have fun bro I'm
the guy from Modern Family the dad I'm
trying you know I'm working I'm
experimenting Sarah Sarah hit Conan with
your question all right Conan one of my
favorite things that you do is your
little spin and the marionette string
dance at the beginning of your show yeah
I'm wondering those are kind of
signature moves now do you know what
context they originally emerged in do
you know or what yes something just
totally random well to answer your
question and by the way a gift from my
great grandfather got great spiritual
meaning to me great comfort you know a
lot of things come out of just killing
time I'm gonna be honest I'm gonna be
all joking aside there's a lot one of
the things that I love so much and this
is being sincere about this format
of doing a show constantly is that your
on TV or on TV or on TV and eventually
you're forced to start finding things
that really that are inside you that
make no sense and so if I did a show one
hour a month or half an hour a week
you'd never see any of this nonsense and
maybe that would be better but for
better or worse the fact that I was on
television starting at the age when I
just turned 30 I started the late night
show and I just was on for thousands and
thousands of hours and before you knew
it I literally was spinning around
growling it ladies licking my nipple
pretending there were strings attached
to my hips and then cutting the
invisible string do I think it's a good
thing to do not necessarily what happens
is the volume of time that you're on
television forces you into this crazy
zone and the next thing you know you're
doing things that you wouldn't do for
you you'd be ashamed to do them for your
best friends and suddenly you're doing
them for 65 million viewers a night
things when I lie but wait a minute
what's that I'm sorry 62 million the
point is this it's the volume and the
silliness and I don't even consciously
remember anyone saying hey Conan would
it what if you did some kind of
marionette move if someone said that to
me and said that's the stupidest thing
I've ever have ever heard of but I like
your signature moves now you know and I
didn't plan that
and I I don't know whether to say thank
you or I'm sorry I apologize I honestly
I things become you know like the way I
wear my hair was never a conscious
decision that just was something I
started doing you know in high school I
don't even know why it's never been
fashion
my haircut has not been fashionable
maybe in 1958 but since then it's been
unanimously rejected and for some reason
that I cannot I just can't tell you why
no one I know wore their hair like this
my brothers and sisters always thought I
look like a fool there's all these
things that just happened and I don't
know why they happened but they happen
so to answer your question I have no
memory of the first time I even did that
foolishness and then I just stand and
why did I stick with it
who would stick with that it's it's kind
of it's absurd but your audience takes
you on a little bit they do yeah that's
the other problem is that I'm very as
you can probably tell I'm very childlike
so all I need is a room full of people
and if there was if they started
chanting drink lava I would well I would
go yeah and I would drink pop and you'd
see lava burn its way through my sternum
and spill out of the floor so yes I'm
very much at the mercy of any group of
people egging me on and again that's
another shameful thing to admit to but
that's do you do you have any rituals
that you go through every night to sort
of get yourself psyched up and into the
zone yeah I thank Satan for all he's
done
clearly it's really the only way I could
get this career and he will claim his
prize in six centuries until then the
show is mine you know what I do I'm
various you can tell I'm very physical
so even though I'm not doing an athletic
event by doing hosting a talk show I do
a lot of stretching before a show I'm
constantly moving and stretching and I'm
really silly with my staff before I do a
show there's not a serious me I have to
almost be a little crazy and stretched
out and out there before I before I go
out and do the program and so
the thing where I just punched Aaron is
something that I do a lot like I I'm
punching people they are allowed to
punch back not very hard
the rule is yeah the rule is they have
to pretend I made out of marzipan
but I'm very physical there's a lot of
me wrestling people and being very silly
and and stretching and jumping up and
down
I'm very affected by music so listening
to the band backstage there's a whole
process that I go through before I even
get out there and it's not even serious
you know I was gonna say when we were on
tour I remember we would just have a big
dance party in the wings like before you
would go on every single night it was
like everybody was dancing in stage
hands and everyone and so it was just
yeah we Meyer that was bad and
unprofessional and we fired everybody
the point is they did do it that's it
they shouldn't have done it
they'd been fired awesome alright surely
I wanna get to your question I surely
hit Conan with your question alright
coming to my question for you is what
are your hidden talents and maybe it's
something you can show us well it'd be
really sad if I had a great hidden
talent and after thirty five thousand
hours of television you had never seen
it I'm sorry to say my my hidden talent
is that I'm funny I've never quite so
met the people I can do this thing or
the kind of spontaneous but I don't know
I don't know anything I heard a great
obviously the greatest you know
talk-show host of all time was Johnny
Carson and Johnny Carson this is related
to me by somebody Johnny Carson once
said you eventually do everything you
know if you have one of these shows and
you do it long enough
meaning if you if there's like a really
weird obscure impression if you're on
for thousands of hours you'll eventually
you'll eventually do that impression if
you are
if there's some very obscure anecdote
you will eventually tell it on the air
you'll eventually pretty much give
people everything you've got if you're
on television enough and that said I am
a I'm an incredible athlete and I'm a
sensualist I'm a sexual dynamo these are
things I don't know people know or
should know those are things that are
just and I would ask you to keep this to
yourselves I'm under the impression it's
just us talking I'm under the impression
yeah but I am I am I'm just an I'm just
an amazing physical specimen
and I I play up this whole I'm pale
little nerdy and stuff but the truth is
I'm very a lot of it's done with makeup
and me I've taken a lot of classes to
affect a certain posture I am incredibly
well built I'm very muscular I am as I
said as a physical specimen I'd be the
first one the aliens would grab this
relates back to you Jason to their
planet you and I would sell them cable
but yeah that's the only thing I think
people don't know about me and and when
I dress as a woman I'm very I'm
shockingly pretty I'm a very pretty
woman when I dress up as a woman
in in the privacy of my own home when my
wife's not around I'm a beautiful you
can laugh if you like but I am a
stunning I'm a Barbara Stanwyck I'm a
classic screen beauty of the 30s that
actually brings me to a question
somebody asked not in our hangout but on
in the comments in Google+ that one
second I hate to interrupt you a guy
from Game of Thrones who carries the kid
around and check it out he is the same
guy I just was told handed this
it says Conan it is 8 p.m. TBS is on the
East Coast
live on I personally don't care I'm
getting so crushed
stop doing this but let's face it
[Laughter]
there's water that needs to be drunk
yeah I think we should relax I think we
should enjoy ourselves and I think
totally lava has happened
it's totally pure lava I'm okay to go a
few more minutes and I'm not running a
show there's a bunch of guys back here
that look like
herckel who are pretty much running the
show I'm happy I like I said I got
nowhere to go I am going to get a very
chilly reception when I go home I'm more
than happy to stay here and let's once
this is done I'm not going to lie to you
I'm going to a sizzler and I'm gonna
just sit there for hours my now outdated
Kendall that's what I do and I drink a
lot of diet dr. pepper so that's my
night I'm happy to keep going and I
think there's something called the DVR
not worried about it I've got a lot of
food here nowhere to go you know I got
nowhere to go and nothing to do so if
you already have to go to watch Conan go
ahead and watch Conan alright but that's
none of my concern
I've seen tonight's show and frankly I
don't think it's a winner well let's
take it we'll take a question from the
Google+ a user ingrid chris hominis I
want to ask Conan what makes you blush
toing what makes you what makes you
blush if anything if anything anything
makes you blush probably a bad time to
ask you it's your mouthpiece full of
delicious chicken listen all right water
now what makes me blush yeah I think the
mention of any other comedians name I'm
just so into myself if someone mentioned
someone else I'm filled with just shame
you know what makes me blush for real I
don't I'm surprisingly old-world you
know for all my joking around I'm raised
fairly Catholic so I get into my zone of
behaving like an idiot but I think you
know I think I would I I think there are
certain kinds of I don't know sexual
forward nests which is offensive in
films
I can't watch Downton Abbey you know I
think it's disgusting I think I you know
what I mean I'd say I won't watch it I
think that should be restricted
television so I am very puritanical and
Victorian in my tastes I block Sesame
Street I won't let my kids watch it
I think it's filth I have a very narrow
window I saw Madagascar the other day
and I look like pornography to me
subjects aliens I just yeah I'm so I am
very I find very little doesn't make me
blush and some of that's because I have
translucent skin I am the whitest person
you'll ever meet and so if there's a
temperature change of one to one and a
half degrees I turn bright red and if I
have a cop drop I turn bright red and
become intoxicated so pretty much
everything makes me blush alright cool
well if you have a few more minutes
maybe we'll do a quick lightning round
everyone gets one more quick question
you guys ready I'm ready
yeah well view left to right again ready
Barry let's go what do you got
alright uh Conan you're here it's gonna
be about space again not the Space Camp
Oh excuse to you're the filmmaker slash
photographer go ahead dude I'm sorry my
question is that your hair is very red
it's a trademark of who you are what are
you gonna do when you get older and
maybe it starts to get a little grey are
you gonna are you going to dye it red
are you going
let it go bring over are you like me no
that actually it'll your hair will never
go gray so you just I do you just kind
of hope that it'll never turn gray like
well first of all this is a very painful
question for Aaron yeah
take a look dude take a look at it it's
only about 24 years old he was when he
was 14 he looked like Newt Gingrich he
is crying throughout this question I'm
Way ahead of all of you I realized my
hair was my trademark so when I was
about 32 I had it completely replaced
polyurethane weave if you move up to
6000 recent intergrade this is a cooking
surface the same material that's used on
the Space Shuttle when it re-enters
orbit it's all so nothing's going this
ain't going anywhere and nothing
happened to it you can't hurt it it's
got a Kevlar base it is really one of
the wonders of science so nothing my
hair will not change even as my face
melts like an ice cream cone pick me up
from my to 10,000 years from now I'll be
a grinning skull with the prettiest hair
you ever saw next question alright
Frederick what you got
alright what are the steps to becoming a
wildly popular talk show host oh this
will be a quick question awesome okay I
spilled coffee no self-esteem have a
rough time in high school insecure
around the ladies be shy changing in
front of other men can't have a bad skin
and then somehow that all works together
and then you got to get really lucky and
yeah I just think basic experience with
fundamental pain and self-hate at an
early age and you know what's really
cool I'm kind of not kidding I'm really
not kidding all right Jase a member
young for Frederick where are you
Frederick
you look like you're in some kind of
aura is it Barry Barry
if Barry where are you
I'm in my house but what you look like
you're in a cube of some kind and I'm in
a cubic blinds see what is that it's
really punished by the elders everyone
else has some kind of human stuff around
them like books or a nice fish painting
or something and you are in what looks
like a bubble or a tube I did some bad
things and I'm okay I'm sorry next
question please Jason I believe it's
your turn and I think it's gonna be
about the Crab Nebula
I wish Conan I was going to ask you know
what your favorite planet was but since
all of your pain and you're paying
viewers are here on earth I think the
answer I think that's that's the answer
to that one so I'm gonna ask you what's
your favorite movie my favorite movie
yeah good question
wow that is a good question you know if
you it's again it's like hard to say
just one but the one move I can watch
either Godfather one or Godfather - I do
not tire of it and I have watched each
one of them about thirty thousand times
but if I go home tonight and we all know
the wife ain't talking to me and I turn
on the TV and there it's one of them's
just beginning if I have to give donate
bone marrow in two hours I will watch it
until I have to go you know I cannot not
watch The Godfather 1 or 2 I also love
being there I love Duck Soup Marx
Brothers WC Fields and just about
anything and I like any of the early red
Shoe Diaries the softcore porn that they
showed on on HBO it's just it has a
classiness to it but you still see
people bottoms which now like bottom
awesome Sarah wood I got a quick
question for Conan before we're before
we wrap up here yeah Conan I have a
question about how you view your
audience like when you're on the stage
do you think more about oh this is a
conversation
between me and Andi are you thinking
about you know looking into the cameras
and thinking about the viewers at home
and performing for them who do you think
about when you're up there performing
your monologues
well actually I never think about the
home viewer I think I'm not good at
abstractions like I never have since the
very beginning the way I have always
done television is I do I try and make
something really funny happen in that
space and then I just trust that it'll
go out over the television you say and
they work you know but when I say you
know not space Jason yeah but I mean I
will I try and make something work in
that environment just the way we're
talking right now I'm not thinking about
whoever else might be watching on Google
or what device or will they watch it
later I'm thinking about just us and
what's happening here and then it's an
act of faith that whatever else happens
if it works my it's sort of the field of
dreams philosophy if you build it they
will come if I can make something funny
happen in that space whether it's you
know the space in New York or a space in
in Los Angeles now or on a talking to a
bunch of college kids in an auditorium
or just a group of us right here I just
think about that moment that group of
people and then I trust the technology
to do the rest awesome all right surely
what do you got
okay Conan so last question I guess is
if you could communicate with any light
form what would you want to know and
from whom hmm kind of adjacent question
interesting I could communicate with any
life form that's correct uh Wow that's
interesting
um I guess dogs you know are interesting
to me I'd like to know I have a dog and
I've always loved dogs and I just love
to know do they are they picking up on
everything maybe they're hypersensitive
and hyper intelligent but they figure it
out this is just a much better deal to
play dumb do you know what I mean
because everything here they've got us
picking up their excrement with our
and can you imagine you know what I mean
if I just was smart enough to walk
around and act like I didn't know and
then I would eventually get all of you
picking up my excrement with your hands
and I'll be like and I really think
there's a good chance that dogs are
geniuses that have just got it
completely worked out and they've got us
feeding them rubbing their asses and and
driving them around for the smallest leg
and we take them and we spend thousands
of dollars getting it removed and so
yeah I think I'd like to talk to dogs
and say I know what you're doing and
it's disgusting to be ashamed of
yourselves because they probably have
the cure for cancer and they know how to
build a faster than you know they have
renewable energy source they know all
that stuff and they're not saying
anything because they want us picking up
their poop and feeding it no I think
there are lowlifes awesome fantastic all
right well before we go Google did a
special thing for us and made Conan they
made your hair and this crazy overlay
thing so before we go to anyone they
made my hair they made your hair and a
thing everybody a there we go everybody
can everybody put on their hair there
you go look at that right perfect nail
this minute they make sure look at the
scene it's a little I don't know that's
perfect
it looks like it looks like a mollusk is
attached to your heads in your brain it
doubles as the Mallis it's supposed to
be kisses you guys have the greatest
technology at your fingertips
orange mollusk on everyone had me Eric
Onan that's wrong back on awesome
alright well thank you guys I think
we've embarrassed all of our hangout
participants enough and thank you Conan
thank you all for listening and watching
at home and this whole Google hangout
will be available tomorrow on Team Coco
comm / hangout and yet the final word
that's coming you let's say goodbye to
everyone
I found this extremely unpleasant
my lawyers are launching a massive suit
against Google as we speak and I haven't
looked into it but I'm guessing my legal
team can be their legal team seriously
thank you everybody it's always I love
talking to people you seem really cool
and I hope you get to do this again and
take that stuff off your head yeah let's
important especially the ladies your
active women and good luck
all right cool thanks guys thank you
everybody and I will see you guys next
time bye bye it's going bye nice to meet
you nice to meet you hon in an errand
everyone